una heladería sirve tres bolas de helado
en su famoso cono aquí hay una imagen de
este cada bola es una esfera con radio
de cuatro centímetros cuál es el volumen
total de helado que se sirve por cono al
centímetro cúbico más cercano y nos
piden usar pi aproximadamente igual a
3.14 sabemos que no es exactamente igual
a 3.14 es 3.14 159 y así hasta el
infinito
algunas personas memorizan cientos de
dígitos y hacen apuestas para ver quién
memoriza más en fin vamos a resolver
esto hay tres bolas de helado aquí la
última no la podemos ver por completo
porque una parte está dentro del cono y
cada una tiene un radio de 4 centímetros
si partimos del centro de la esfera
hasta la superficie de la esfera tenemos
4 centímetros lo que tenemos que hacer
es calcular el volumen de una de estas
esferas o de estas bolas y multiplicarlo
por 3 ya que tenemos 3 esferas y cada
una tiene un radio de 4 centímetros por
lo que todas tienen el mismo volumen
hacerlo necesitamos recordar la fórmula
del volumen de una esfera el volumen de
una esfera es igual a cuatro tercios por
pi por r al cubo donde r es el radio de
la esfera en este caso es de cuatro
centímetros y pi es el famoso número que
surge de la razón entre la
circunferencia y el diámetro del círculo
para los efectos de este ejercicio vamos
a establecer que pi es igual a 3.14 pero
muchas calculadoras tienen una
representación mucho más precisa que
está aquí uso 3.14 porque es lo que nos
piden hacer así que el volumen de una
esfera es cuatro tercios por 3.14 como
pi por el radio al cubo el radio es de 4
centímetros que vamos a elevar al cubo y
si tenemos algo en centímetros y lo
elevamos al cubo vamos a tener como
unidades centímetros cúbicos de hecho
vamos a hacerlo 4 centímetros al cubo
este va a ser el volumen de una de las
esferas y tenemos tres de ellas por lo
que vamos a multiplicar esto por tres
para tener el volumen combinado
hecho simplifica nuestros cálculos
tenemos 3 entre 3 y nos queda 4 por 3.14
que si quisiéramos ser más precisos
diríamos que es pi
esto es sólo una aproximación de pi y 4
centímetros al cubo es 4 al cubo es 4 x
4 es 16 por 4 64 por lo que esto es 64
centímetros cúbicos que también podemos
pensar cómo elevar al cubo las
dimensiones centímetros al cubo son
centímetros cúbicos por lo que el
volumen son estos centímetros cúbicos
podemos hacer esto a mano 4 x 64 es 256
por lo que es 3.14 por 256 centímetros
cúbicos pero nos permiten usar la
calculadora en este problema así que la
usamos y multiplicamos 3.14 por 256 que
es igual a 800 3.84 y nos piden
redondear al centímetro cúbico más
cercano por lo que redondeamos 800 3.84
hacia arriba por el 84 que tenemos aquí
por lo que es ochocientos cuatro
centímetros cúbicos esto es
aproximadamente igual a ochocientos
cuatro centímetros cúbicos
este es el volumen de estas tres esferas
combinadas